the Joe Rogan experience yeah peace to
me peace is happiness at rest and
happiness is kind of peace in motion you
can convert peace to happiness anytime
you want but peace is what you want most
of the time that's interesting you can
convert peace to happiness anytime you
want yeah if you're a peaceful person
anything you do will be a happy activity
mmm and by the way being on social media
and engaging politics will not bring you
peace there is nothing less peaceful
right and then today's day and age the
way we think you get peace is by
resolving all your external problems but
there's unlimited external problems so
the only way to actually get pieces on
the inside by giving up this idea of
problems who thinks you can get peace by
resolving external problems other than
politicians everybody that's not
everybody's struggling to do right why
are you trying to make money to solve
all your money problems mmm
why are you trying to win up politics
because then you'll be at peace because
your people will have won well it's a
daunting task to get your [ __ ] together
it's easier to change yourself than to
change the world that's true and the
best way to change the world is to
change yourself exactly it's all yeah
it's all these people who are shouting
on social media the best way is just to
actually live the life that you want
other people to live like I went out in
New Zealand and there's this guy that I
met with and you know everyone's on
social media shouting about
environmentalism and conserve and
sustain and I go to this guy's house and
he was doing a very quietly very gently
he was doing a two-week long zero waste
experiment where he was throwing out
nothing so every package that he opened
he would keep and he would like clean it
up so he'd keep his Amazon boxes it
keeps a little container even a tea bag
if he opened the tea bag he has to
figure out how to compost the tea inside
how to make the tea itself useful how to
make the tea bag like a little storage
item so there was no trash he was
literally living with zero trash waste
and he was doing it and it was really
inspirational meeting people like him
made me far more environmentally
conscious than you know any amount of
people yelling at me on social media
ever will
how long did he do that for I think it
was two weeks it was hard what the [ __ ]
you gonna do with tea bags
he had quite the collection see you back
in Philly men with little things he
sounds like a crazy hoarder like a
hoarder personal acts of tea bags in his
house
very impressive guy yeah that's a
strange way to go about things I
appreciated that meaning look it is
entirely possible to somehow or another
engineer all of our cups and all of our
things and all are about to be
biodegradable okay you know the struggle
with a modern environmental movement is
that they identify the correct problem
which is finite earth
spaceship or the zoning god don't ruin
it but they don't have the solution so
what they say is no growth no growth no
growth well the problem is you got three
billion Indian and Chinese who aren't
gonna stay in poverty they're gonna grow
whether you like it or not so you can
yell at them you can scream at them you
can yell at us and scream at us but
that's not gonna happen
so the only way out unfortunately is
again through technology which is you
have to build green technology and I
give musk a lot of credit you know for
being one of the few people who's out
there trying to do that so you build
things that are biodegradable and good
for you and healthier and everybody
wants to be healthier Chinese want to be
healthier Indians want to be healthy or
they want to be cleaner if you say I can
clean up your rivers I can clean up your
forests I can have your children not get
sick with cholera and diphtheria and
typhoid I can cure your diseases that
can help make your immune system
stronger I can give you clean drinking
water like that is what causes people to
become environmentalist not shouting and
screaming it then that they shouldn't
grow and they should stop pumping things
into the sky and you know they have no
concept of that they're just gonna get
out of poverty so I think the modern
environmental movement identifies the
correct problem but then doesn't come up
with the right set of solutions that are
appealing to people people are not going
to give up economic growth they're gonna
have to get rich first mmm yeah that's a
very good point but how do you do how do
you do both you lower the price of clean
technologies massively so you basically
make clean technologies cost competitive
innovation ideally you can subsidize in
the short term medium term until the
innovation curve is is crossed I mean
like Tesla doesn't have any patent
right well they they freely give away
their patents that's an example of how
you can do it so you know someone in if
you want to get rid of plastics so two
straws yeah you can do it here and there
you can get San Francisco to ban plastic
straws but China is not gonna blend
banned plastic straws not until you
build a paper straw that is you know
same cost good durability and then you
in and then you educate in Chinese like
hey this is petroleum you know this
plastic that your dream is petroleum is
bad for you here's the chemical
composition here's the things that are
going in your bloodstream and they want
healthy happy kids also so they're gonna
have their kids use paper straws maybe
straws aren't the best example but you
can you know this is true with fossil
fuels for example that's that's probably
the best one or replacing a lot of
plastics with glass and paper and so on
yeah there's a new technology that was
just rhonda patrick had another twitter
today about they're able to convert
plastic waste into fuel and that there's
companies that are actively trying to do
that now so then in that way plastic
waste will become valuable right it'll
become a commodity and become something
that people are resource now there's
certain problems this doesn't solve this
doesn't solve carbon this doesn't solve
deforestation you know so they're you
kind of have to step in with other means
so for example look at the amazon right
everyone's complaining about the amazon
being deforested well you're not the
poor brazilian farmer so you're sitting
here and your comfortable chair like
social media hammering away at you know
the evil Brazilians were DeForest in the
Amazon but the Amazon has incredible
resources if we really care about it we
should turn it into an incredible
tourist Park and put your money where
your mouth is start doing ecotourism in
the Amazon start paying for it and then
maybe take the future rights for all the
pharmaceuticals they're gonna come out
of all the incredible plants there and
start selling those off so that people
so that maybe give the pharmaceutical
companies an incentive to preserve the
biodiversity the Amazon say hey if you
buy this patch of the Amazon you
conservative and you can serve it
whatever plant medicines that come out
of there that you can then license you
get the patent for 20 years or 30 years
or whatever so I think there are
solutions where we as the first world
herbs will have money can put our money
where where our mouth is and go and
rescue these kinds of properties that's
a very interesting solution but I could
see
immediately pushback from people that
don't think the pharmaceutical company
should have the rights to this natural
plant or is or the core the government
does it and then the government gets the
patents and the government will auction
off the patents later or they're worse
or they're licensing or whatever it is
right well I thought in like just this
the often the problem is there is no
really good solution there's a bunch of
solutions that also have drawbacks
that's life yeah that's the trade-off so
it's being human yeah very messy yeah
it's a constrained environment obviously
I skew more toward as a private property
capitalist type solutions because even
though they're not perfect they have
been proven to actually work right once
something is your property you take care
of it yeah you're not gonna you're not
gonna crap all over your own house but
it should probably be temporary property
not permanent property you see a lot of
countries around the world not doing
this no foreign ownership of land thing
for example or Mexico has no private
ownership of beaches right so you can
draw the line at certain points mm-hmm
yeah